welcome back the center serves as a
haven for all but especially
for our lbgtqia plus community
as we enjoy our second day of pride
month i checked in with the center to
see how we can support and enjoy their
long fabulous list of celebrations check
this out
hey jim happy friday hey happy pride to
you
good to see you you too how you doing
good and it's only day two of a crazy
month
it's only day two of pride month and of
course of the reopen
so how is the center of las vegas
celebrating both of those things
uh how long do we have exactly um
you know i i'm i'm i'm 54 years old and
i was talking to someone who was 22
yesterday and i said it's amazing that
we're celebrating pride month
and there's so much happening because
years passed
there were very few things happening and
i i think
i i'm going to blame 2020 for being so
terrible boring
that we've decided to to to like go
non-stop
not only did our city open pride month
happened when it opened so it's
we're running we're running like
chickens with our heads cut off but you
know it's an
it's amazing thing to have this much
pride and
seeing it everywhere everywhere i know
it's kind of like
we're all coming out right yes
yes i can hear that song right now
right right exactly so let's talk about
the events um that we can enjoy and that
you guys are putting on for everybody
i i tell everybody go to our social
media go to go to
to the lgbtq center of southern nevada
for our facebook
uh the center lv instagram the center lv
on on twitter um social media is where
we're putting everything because that's
where it's at today
i'm old school i'm still learning my
facebook live
but we have so much happening not only
here at the center
but we have so many allies and community
partners who have reached out to us
saying
you're up you're going we've made it
through how can we help the community
and we
we have we have things happening
everywhere the the diversity of just our
programs and our events alone
is crazy from fashion shows to big time
wrestling
to to barbecues to simple little outings
in the park to theater to drag shows
you name it it's there it's happening
that's so fabulous but but this
besides the fun um and the education
we're also celebrating the or
acknowledging the history
i try to get our youth programs involved
with our senior programs too
to let let to hear stories because
everyone's history is different
and yes we we are we are celebrating and
we are honoring the
memories of those who who fought before
us and and it all started with a rock
and glass
at stonewall and for for the trans
individuals in the trans community
who are still this day this day fighting
for their rights to to just be a part of
our community
those are the stories we like to tell at
all of our events but
the most important message i think i can
tell everyone
is we we celebrate proud being proud
and our pride every day
oh that's awesome yeah there's so much
going on there was a flyer at the fire
did he say big time wrestling somewhere
in there he did he did i need that fire
i need that guy are you going to that
one
yeah that sounds awesome now the
venetian